Let's get into it.
Before we jump into it, guys, I want to share with you a quick story.
When I was doing door-to-door sales, and I promise I'm going to make this really quick,
when I was doing door-to-door sales, they would literally drop us off in neighborhoods
and we would just start knocking doors.
And I am not the sharpest tool in the shed, as they say, but I learned really quickly
If I would just knock on the homes of people who already had security systems, so like
ADT or Monotronics, these different companies, I would look for those security signs.
When I knocked on these houses, in the beginning I didn't do it on purpose, and I knocked on
these houses, it was a really different sale, it was a completely different thing.
I didn't have to convince them that they should get security, I didn't have to convince them
that security was a good idea.
I didn't have them telling me, oh, I have a gun, I have Smith & Wesson, I have a dog,
it's a safe neighbor.
I didn't have these objections because they were already paying for security.
So what was cool is I would knock on these doors, and my pitch was very simple, it was
like, I would knock and I would say, hey, my name's Nick, blah blah blah, I'm with this
company right here, I know you're already paying for XYZ service and I already know
how much you're paying, what we're doing for everybody in the neighborhood is we're just
upgrading them, we're giving them a camera, we're giving them a door lock, we're giving
them this, we're upgrading their system, it's the same price per month, roughly, and we're
going to put you on a phone app, can I step inside and show you what this looks like on
paper?
And that was it, and I was right inside the house, we were talking numbers.
It wasn't this big emotional sale, it wasn't this long, dry-out thing, it was very, very
cut and dry.
And so what it did, and this is what I want to talk about, is this collapsed time.
I was trying, every single year when I was doing this job, I was like, how do I make
more sales?
How do I make more sales?
And I didn't have the leverage of the internet or any of these tools, it was literally sweat
equity.
How can I get more deals done in less amount of time?
And the way that I was able to do this is by collapsing time, and it was by going after
these type of customers.
Guys, there's three things I want to share here as to why we're going to target people
that are already paying for ads.
Number one is when you call people and you target people that are already paying for
ads, already sold on what you're selling, you only need to make one sale.
What I mean by that is you don't need to call a business owner and convince them that, hey,
Mr. Business Owner, advertising is a good idea.
You don't need to do that because they already know they're already paying for it.
So what it is, all you need to do is you need to let them know, hey, Mr. Business Owner,
here's why you should work with me.
Here's why my product is better than what you're paying for, or not even better than,
but also a good fit, okay?
So you only need to make one sale.
Second reason is you're going to have to talk to less people to get deals.
You're not going to have to go through so many people to find a deal.
When you just go and you're targeting and you're prospecting and you just go to Google
and you type in concrete Minneapolis, you're going to have to go through a lot of business
owners to find people that are sold on your product and then sold on you, and it's going
to take a long time.
But when you're specifically targeting people who are already sold, you're going to get
a deal a lot quicker, and you're going to have to go through a lot less heartache, headache,
pain to get to that deal.
Third reason is this, guys.
When you're talking to people that are already sold on what you're selling, they conceptually
understand, okay, I pay for advertising because it's going to get me more business, I understand
what leads are, and so what this does is it allows you to collapse time.
They conceptually understand the concept of paying for advertising, and so these deals
tend to go a lot quicker.
When you're talking to somebody who's never spent money on ads, they've never spent money
on Google Ads, Home Advisor, Angie's List, et cetera, you have to explain everything.
Hey, Mr. Business Owner, this is what cost per click is.
Hey, Mr. Business Owner, this is how a lead is, or this is what a lead is.
Hey, Mr. Business Owner, this is what the customer sees.
Hey, Mr. Business Owner, this is why we're better than Google Ads.
But when they're already paying for advertising, you don't have to do all that.
They conceptually understand it, and these deals tend to go quicker.
So guys, let's go ahead and build the list.